hi everyone i am umbra suhil welcome to
simply launch youtube channel
in this session here we will learn the
basic price pack for beginners
if you want more amazing tech related
videos do like and subscribe and hit the
bell icon to stay tuned
now let's get to the video to learn more
about pi spark without any further delay
we will begin the session by discussing
apache spark overview
and what is pi spark
then we will have a look at key features
of pi spark
moving forward we will understand the
difference between scala and pi spark
and then the use case of pi spark in
industries after that we will understand
what is spicebox data frame
and its various features
and finally we will end the session by
discussing how to create data frame now
have a look at why is pi spark so
popular pi spark is so popular because
it's a first class spark api that is
well supported and a fantastic option
for most businesses
spark is faster than the other big data
solutions and can handle more than 100
tasks at once which make it more suited
to an in-memory model
the procedure is sped up and take much
less time because of sparks in memory
processing
spark is an open source cluster
computing framework that is used to
develop big data applications that can
perform fast analytics over large data
sets
spark is written in scala but it can
also be used from python using pi smart
it is very popular and one of the most
requested tools in the it industry
because it has inbuilt tools for resql
machine learning and streaming
so now that we understand apache spark
it will be easier for us to understand
pispah so let's dive into it
pi spark is a python api to support
python with apache spark
python can easily be connected with the
purchase part using the pi spark
provided by folder library
when it comes to analyzing or working
with large data sets pi spot is
essential
pi spark is a python api to support
python with apache spa
python can easily be connected with
apache spark using the pi spark provided
by 4j library
when it comes to analyzing or working
with large data sets pi spark is
essential
pi spark is a mostly search tool among
data engineers because of its
functionality
so now that we understood about pi spark
now we shall move on to its features
real-time computing
pi spark focuses on in-memory processing
and offers real-time computing on
massive amounts of data
so the low latency is evident
the next feature which comes in is
support for several languages
scala java python and are just a few
programming languages with which the pi
spark framework is compatible
because of its interoperability it is
the best framework for processing large
datasets
the next feature we have is consistency
of disk and caching
the pi spark frameworks offer powerful
caching and reality this consistency
as we know time is money and to work
effectively we need powerful and fast
processing so the next amazing feature
of pi spark is rapid processing
with buy spark we can process data
quickly roughly hundred times quicker in
memory and 10 times faster on the disk
so now we have come to the most
important feature of pi spark which is
effectiveness with rdd
working with rdd is made easier by the
dynamic typing of python programming
languages
if you are wondering what rdd is let me
give you a quick explanation of rdd
let's learn more about rdd
rdd stands for resilient distributed
data set it is apache sparks primary
data structure
rdd in apache spark is an immutable
group of objects that computes on
several cluster nodes
resilient with the use of rdd lineage
graph the system is resilient of fault
tolerant
and is therefore able to recompute
missing or damaged partitions as a
result of node failure
now we have a better understanding of pi
spark and its features so let's
understand the need of pi spark
it's crucial to understand why and when
to use spark with python if you are
going to learn pi spark
here we will go over the basic factors
to consider while deciding between
python and scala for apache spark
programming
data science libraries
you don't have to bother about the
visuals or data science frameworks with
the python api
the r language's fundamental component
can readily convert it to python
the next factor which comes in is
readability of code
although internal modifications are
simple in the scala api
the python epa offers superior
readability maintenance and familiarity
with the code
complexity
in contrast to scala which produces
verbose output and is therefore viewed
as a complicated language
so the python api provides an accessible
simple and comprehensive interface
moving on to next factor
machine learning libraries
since python offers several libraries
based on machine learning approaches it
is popular for developing machine
learning algorithm because it makes the
process simpler
so now let's discuss the last factor on
our list ease of learning
python is simpler to learn and is known
for its simple syntax
in comparison to scala which has a
complex syntax and is difficult to learn
it is also extremely productive despite
having a basic syntax
if you are new to big data you have
probably heard of frameworks such as
spark
that technologies can be in python or
scala
how do you choose programming languages
to answer this question we must consider
various factors
let us figure out the answer to this
question by understanding the difference
between the two
firstly let's discuss the difference
between compiled versus interpreted
one of the major differences is that
python is an interpreted language which
makes it quite handy when coding whereas
scala requires you to compile your code
for it to be executed by the java
virtual machine
this process result in a file containing
bytecode
so the next difference is based on the
performance
spark offers two apis the high level one
where data frames and data sets are
found and the low level one which uses
resilient distributed data sets
scala offers superior performance with
rdds because python has an additional
communication overhead with the jvm
however python should not cause you any
performance issue
moving on to another difference that is
based on type safety
python has a dynamic typing whereas the
scala has static typing
when using dynamic typing the type of
the variable you are defining is not
specified
your code becomes simpler as a result in
python the type of your variable can be
derived by writing its name and
assigning a value
now what's the difference when it comes
to a learning curve
it's typically easier to learn python
than scala if you are just a beginner in
any of the languages
python has a progressive learning curve
but once you get the hang of it you can
use the same simple syntax you started
with to do the advanced task
let's discuss the difference based on
the community support
python has a much larger user base than
scala which can help it gain support
as a result python benefits from more
comprehensive libraries devoted to task
complexity
scala does have robust support it is
still far beyond python
finally let's discuss the last
difference in our list based on the
project scale
python is a smart decision if you wish
to work on a smaller project with less
seasoned programmers
however scala is the ideal option for a
large project that requires numerous
resources and parallel processing
let's discuss the difference based on
community support
python has a much larger user base than
scala which can help it gain support
as a result python benefits from more
comprehensive libraries devoted to
various task complexity
scala does have robust support it is
still far beyond python
finally
let's discuss the last difference in our
list based on the project scale
python is a smart decision if you wish
to work on a smaller project with less
seasoned programmers
however scala is the ideal option for a
large project that requires numerous
resource and parallel processing
after learning different topics about pi
spark in the session we have reached our
final topic which is pi sparks use in
industries let's take a look at it
apache spark is gaining popularity and
becoming more widely used by its users
from startups to multinationals
apache spark has been used to create
develop and innovate big data systems
here are various spark use examples for
particular industries that show how to
create and execute quick large data apps
ecommerce industry let's understand this
with an example
like shopify wanted to analyze the kinds
of goods its clients were selling in
order to find suitable retailers with
home it may collaborate in order to grow
its business
its data warehousing infrastructure was
unable to resolve this issue since its
frequently timed out when processing
data mining queries on millions of
documents
shopify successfully developed a list of
stores for collaboration after
processing 67 million entries using
apache spark in a matter of minutes
the next use case of pi spark is in
healthcare industries
a healthcare spark is used in genomic
sequencing
prior to spark organizing all the
chemicals compound with the genes took
several weeks
with spark it only took a few hours now
myfitnesspal
the biggest health and fitness community
use cases of pi spark in industry
apache spark is gaining popularity and
becoming more widely used by its users
from startups to multinationals apache
spark has been used to create develop
and innovate big data systems
here are various spark use examples for
particular industries that show how to
create and execute quick large data apps
firstly we have e-commerce industry
let's understand with this an example
like shopify wanted to analyze the kinds
of goods its clients were selling in
order to find suitable details before it
may collaborate in order to grow its
business
its data warehousing infrastructure was
unable to resolve this issue since it
frequently time out when processing data
mining queries on millions of documents
shopify successfully developed a list of
stores where collaboration after
processing 67 million entries using
apache spark in a matter of minutes
the next use case of pi spark is in
healthcare industries
spark is used in genomic sequencing
priority to spark organizing all the
chemical compounds with genes took
several weeks
with spark it only tooks a few hours
only
myfitnesspal the biggest health and
fitness community uses spark to clean
user inter data with the ultimate
purpose of identifying high quality food
products the food calorie information of
roughly 80 million individuals has been
scanned by myfitnesspal using spark
media and entertainment
with the help of apache spark pinterest
is able to identify patents and very
valuable user engagement data so that it
can quickly respond to emerging trends
by gaining a through understanding of
users online behavior
to offer online suggestion to its users
netflix leverages spark for real time
stream analysis
another best use of pi spark is in
software and information service
the spark developers have created data
breaks it is a platform that has been
tailored for the cloud to run spark and
ml apps on aws and azure
as well as a through training course
in order to grow the project in advance
they are working on spark
financial services provider finra assist
in gaining real-time data insight from
billions of data occurrences
it can test things on actual market data
using apache spark
last but not the least pi spark is used
in travel industry as well
let's learn more about it
apache spark uses in the travel sector
is growing quickly
it facilitates consumer flawless
traveling planning by expectating
customized recommendation
by comparing numerous websites they may
also utilize it to advise to list on
where to group hotels
spark is being used by tripadvisor a
popular travel website that assists
consumer in creating the ideal tip to
speed up its tailored client suggestions
we have introduction to pi spark
introduction to pi spark
python pixbox provides an interface for
apache spark
it enables you to create spark
application using the python apis and
give you access to the pi spark shell
enabling interactive data analysis in a
distributed setting
most of the pi spark functionality
including spark sql data frame streaming
mlib and spark core are supported by pi
spark
to build more scalable analysis and
pipelines pi spark is a useful language
to learn if you are already familiar
with python tools like pandas
next is what is spy spot data frame a
distributed grouping of rows with name
columns is known as a data frame
in layman's terms it is equivalent to an
excel sheet with columns header or a
table in a relational database
additionally
it has several traits in common with rdt
we can create a data frame or rdd only
once we cannot modify it after applying
transformations our data frame or rdd
can be transformed
in other words a task is not carried out
until an action is taken
both the rdd and the data frame have a
distributed design
i'm sure you might be wondering why
exactly we need data frames now let's
discuss that
data frames features
distributed data frames are distributed
data collections that are arranged into
rows and columns in pi spark
our data frame has a name and the type
for each column
data frames are comparable to
conventional database tables in that
they are organized and brief
the next feature is lazy evolution
although scala may be executed lazily
and spark is written in scala
spark's default execution mode is lazy
this means that up until the action is
involved no operation over an rdd
data frame or data set are ever computed
next is immutable
immutable storage includes data frames
data sets and rdd
the world immutability means inability
to change
when used in reference to an object it
signifies that its state cannot be
changed once it is formed compared to
python these data frames are immutable
and provide less flexibility than
manipulating rows and columns
now we are going to look at the demo how
to create data frames
let's go ahead and create some data
frames so now i used google cloud
instead of pi spark shell
as i personally find it easier to work
with
it comes down to your choice so guys
let's go ahead and start that demo
so now i will show you how to create a
data frame in pricebar firstly we need
to have spark configured on our device
to use the file function
for this you need to open your command
prompt and then type in this command to
install python pid install
so now here we are ready to get started
we can create our data frame in price
park shell
but i prefer to use google collab for
myself you can choose to do with you
know pi spark shell or jupiter notebook
also
so
here let us open a new notebook
now firstly we will have to set up a
price pack
so we will type in the same command pip
install by spark
now as you can see that pi spark is set
up we can move on to creating an example
of data frame for departments and
students
[Music]
so now as you can see my spark is
setting up
importing price
importing five spa sql
now as you can see that by spark is set
up we can move on to create an example
data frame for departments and student
so now after the import is successful i
am going to create a student database
using the row function
students equal to row
it consists of columns named as first
name last name a name page and row
number
so now we will create data for some
students
now in students we have columns named as
first name last name
email
age and number
so now we will create data for some
students
we will write student one equal to
certain
then inside this brackets we by john
like the first name
then the amarr which is the last name
then we will write the email
age and roll number
again we will do the same for the rest
of them like we will just copy this one
and then paste after that we will change
the specific first name and last name
email id etc
like also then two three four and five
also we will change the specific name
like student 2 is cassie
and there is no surname so we have to
write none
[Music]
then we will come to lois
because lois has a last name so it will
be lopez
it's
so sudan for his chap
and his surname is doris
because he don't have a email id so it
will be none
and the 8 is 23
so for student five who is
michael
we will do the same procedure
as the surname is reaction
and the main name is i repeat and the
email is michael at the rate of
unique or same
as you can see that all these students
data are in the same format as given
first name last name
agent roll number
so let us create some department data as
well
so now we will go on text
and
let's create
the department
again we will use the row function
so department one equals row then inside
the brackets
id is equal to 0 0 1 we can take
and name is equal to subject
so name is equal to maths
the subject
or whatever you want to take
now coming to department 2 it will be
the same as department one
just have to enter the row
and inside the bracket
the same id is equal to whatever the id
you want to take
because we are going in the serial
number so it should be zero zero two
zero zero one
and
name is equal to
we should take english
now coming to department 3
it will also go same
starting with the row
id
that is 003
and again the name of the subject
we can take for sex
so
it will also go safe for the department
form
we should just copy and paste
zero zero four
name of the subject of chemistry
or whatever you want to
think
so now suppose you want to look at the
values of student 2
we will use the print command to print
student 2
so let's do
come into code
and now print
in bracket
student 2
so you can see here the values of row
student 2
the first name is cassie last name is
not specified so it has been printed as
null value
before moving further we should check if
there is any error or correction we
should make
let's see okay
so
there are some double quotes
and email is also missing
as you can see only the single quotes
will work
and because we mentioned the email for
other students so we have to mention the
email in the elements also
so
yeah
okay so it's all fine let's have a look
let's just cross check and run that
yeah it's working
so
moving forward
so you can see here the values of row so
student 2 the first name is cassie last
name is not specified
so it has been printed as null value
then we have the email cassie at the
rate of uni
dot sem
under ages 22
and roll number which is 14526
so now see how easy it is to use python
and now we can also create some
instances for our departments and
students data okay and also we have to
click on the text post
then
we have to write only create the
department
with
student instances
instances
tab
so
now we have to click on the code
so as for department student 1 is equal
to
department student 1 is equal to row
and inside its department is equal to
department one
and student is equal to student one and
student two
now for the others we just have to copy
this
and paste like we have done earlier
and you just have to change the
serial number of student
department
here we are creating some instances
which shows us the student each
department consists of
let me show you how it is done
so you just need to execute the command
so
so we just have to go on the code
and type
print
department
with student 3 we will take student 3.
now we should cross check first
let's see if there is some mistake or
something okay
so we have to correct this
now we should run and check
if it was running or not
okay huh so here's the output
we get the roll number which is one
three five three six now finally we can
create our data frame
let us create an array of sequence of
instances for our data frame
so
let's start
creating data frame
now we will go again on the code
and
department
with students
is equal to
department with student one
and then
department with student two and then
department of student three would get
along
okay department is two and three
here department one consists of student
1
and department 2 consists of students 3
and 4 and department three consists of
student four and five
then we need to create spark context
using from pi spark
dot context so we are gonna write
uh we should go on code first
after selecting the code
we need to create spark context using
from pi stock
okay
five spark
dot
context
import spark context
and then
from
from pi spark dot
sql dot session
import spark session
sc is equal to spam
so basically after this we can create
data frame
using department with students
so let's
go on the text
so now let's run this program let's see
if it is working
okay
so now moving forward
we'll go to the code then
df is equal to spark dot create
data frame
df that is the department for student
now we will go to the text
and
let's
go for display data frame
so now we can display our data frame
using display function so let's go to
the code again
and write display function
that is df
so now
as you see we have the structure of
department which consists of two strings
id and name and the student array which
consists of three strings first name
last name and email and two integer
values which are age and row number
now as you know how to create a data
frame let us move on the covet pandemic
use case
so here we have the data of all the
countries affected by kovic 19 pandemic
and it is the csv format so i am going
to show you how it is done
firstly we will import spark session
from pi spark sql using the command so
let's do that
so before going further we should run
this first
and let's see
yeah
so
now we will go to the text and write a
data frame from csv
because i'm going to show how it is done
so
firstly we will import spark session
from pi spark sql using the command
that is from pi spark
dot sql
spark session
let's run this also
yeah
so
now let's initiate the spark session to
create a data frame by executing the
following command
that is
spark let's go to the code again and
write
spark is equal to
spark session
dot builder
dot app
dot app name
and then in bracket
create data frame
from csv file
because here we are learning how to
create this data frame from csv file
so create data frame from csv file
get or create
so now as the spark session is initiated
we can use the spark dot read command to
read the csv file and convert it into
our data frame which we have named as
poet 19 underscore df
so let's again go to the code
okay so before that we should run this
code first
so it's not
okay
i believe there must be some syntax
error
let's find out okay
so
this should be capital
noise will work i guess yeah it's
working
so now as the spark session is initiated
we can use the spark dot read command to
read the csv file of course
and convert it into our data frame which
we have named as kovite underscore tf
so let's
go it
go to the code we are already in the
code
so go with underscore df
is equal to
spark dot read
csv
then in the bracket
path is equal to
double quotes
and then content countrywise latest csv
underscore is underscore latest dot csv
dot csv
okay
so here as you see i have provided a
path
to the csv file you can do this by
uploading it on collab
so let me show you how it is done
so as it is uploaded now we can right
click on the file and copy the path into
our spark.read command
otherwise if you are doing it in the spy
spark shell you can directly copy the
path of the file from the local
directory
we have used comma as a separator and as
you see i have set header equal to true
this is because otherwise the data frame
would take the first row as the initial
values of the data set
so now after successful execution of the
command our data
which we are going to
so yeah it's running
so now i will tell you how to upload
this file let's go into the files
on the document
then
i have already uploaded this file that's
country wisely
so you just have to choose the file
and it will be visible on your screen
as you can see here
so
with the next step
now after successful execution of the
command our data is created
and now let's try out some commands
which we can use on our data plane
so let's go to the
code firstly let us use the dot show
command to display our data frame that
is go with underscore df show
so now let's check first if it's correct
or not
yeah it's working and we have the data
set here
so now as you can see here we have the
country or region number of confirmed
cases active cases recovered cases
number of death and so on
now to look at the total number of
records in our data frame we can use
covet underscore df count so for that we
have to go to the code again
okay
so let's type covent underscore
df dot com
sorry
dot com okay
so with this
we should also check it first
i hope it's working
yeah
we have the output
so here we have total 187d cons or rows
in our data frame
now if you want to see the columns
although we have seen it using the
df.show function
but if you want to see just the name of
column separately you can use
go with underscore df dot columns
so
df
dot
count
first we have to
run it
okay okay so there is a correction
actually there should
be
a column
instead of
[Music]
so
i run the code
and
that's the output
so as you can see here we have all the
columns listed out
now here we can simply count the number
of columns but for more complex data
frame
we can use
len kovat df columns for that we have to
go to code again
and
then in brick it
go with
underscore
tf
df
dot
columns
and packet closed
let's run this
so now you can see there are 15 columns
in our data frame
now let's print the schema of our data
frame
let's go to code again
we have to write
go with sorry
go with underscore
df
dot
print
camera
and
closed so let's run this also
okay
so as you can see the types of column we
have been mentioned here and you can set
no label as their either true or false
because in some data frames maybe some
of the values are supposed to be null
so moving on further you can also
describe a particular column
using
covet
underscore
df dot to
describe
and bracket
we should use double quote yeah
so
world health organization reason
no sorry we should use
a
single
single point
because it will not work with other ones
okay so dot
show
and then yeah
so
as you can see the column
w ato region have been described here
count is equal to 187
that means it has total 1870 codes
so here mean and standard deviation are
null
as we have string values
so the minimum value is africa and the
maximum is western pacific
alphabetically
we can also describe one more column as
per
let's go to code first
with
covet
underscore
df dot to
subscribe
okay
dot
show
let's run this
here also count of total record is 187
and name value is approx to 34 000
and the standard deviation is near about
21 2326
and the minimum and maximum values are
given as zero
and 98
752
so now we can also select a particular
column or more than one column to show
their details
by using
so
don't select
[Music]
okay
single coil
country
slash
vision
[Music]
space slash space
handed kisses
dot show let's see if it's working
okay so it's working
here you can see the data of two columns
separately
we also have a filter function to filter
out the data of a particular column at
given position
and also we can do that by using
govet
underscore
df
filter
intricate
covet
underscore
df dot
dates
thousand
dot
show
okay
here we can see all the records in our
data frame where the death count is
greater than 1 000.
we can also count the number of records
shown in by the above command using
count function instead of using show
function
so for that
uh let's see what is the command
function that is called underscore df
dot to filter
go with
we have used the same command actually
that we had used earlier but instead of
show you just have to write count
so
because you are using count function
here
instead of show just you have to write
count
that's it
let's run
that is 44 so the total number of record
in the data frame with more than 1000
deaths is 44.
huh we can also filter out more than one
condition like this and for that let's
see
go to code
the command should be
covet
underscore tier
dot filter
double brackets
that's
greater than one
000 of course because we have used this
information earlier also
and
call it
underscore
sorry
go with underscore
active
that is greater than
10 000
just closed okay
door
show don't forget to close it okay
let's run this program
let's cross check what's the error
coming you also have to take care of the
small mistakes
go ahead and underscore df dot filter
double click it yeah so here's the
mistake
underscore
go with dot debt
greater than 1000
and
here's also one mistake yeah
so go back to and let's go dot active
ten thousand dot show let's run it again
so it work now here we all the requests
where the date count is greater than
1000 and also the number of active cases
is greater than 10 000.
we can also use order by function to
arrange our data frame in ascending or
descending order so for that
we have to use the command
that is
covet
underscore tf
dot order
dot order
by
in bracket
active
dot show
let's run it
so the error is
here
okay
this is called camel casing
b should be captain and y should be
small
okay so let's run it again
yeah
so as you can see data in our data frame
is arranged in ascending order
now we will try on running some sql
queries on our data frame first
we need to
create a temporary table using
the command
i'm using the
[Music]
command coverage underscore tf
dot
register
temp
table
in bracket
covet
sorry c should be capital
go with
underscore
table now we can use the command
that is
spark
dot to
sql
in bracket
single
quote
select
from code table
dot show
so
to show all the content of the table we
can also select a particular column
using
this last
command
that is
spark dot
sql
in bracket
select
sorry
recovered
from
it
[Music]
okay
dot
show
so you can see the data from a
particular column of the table is
fetched out
basically these were the top 10
functions
so with this we have come to the end of
the session on pi spark i hope you found
the session both interesting and
exciting if you have any questions about
any of the topic covered in this session
or if you need the resources used in
this session please let us know in
comment section below and our team of
experts will be pleased to respond as
soon as possible
thank you until next time this is umrah
from the assembly line team signing off
continue to learn and stay safe
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here